heather is with us and where's he at in
cleveland good afternoon heather
how can i help you hi greetings from
ohio
my name is heather and my question is is
it necessary to have a credit score and
the reason why i'm wondering this
is because my own parents have um
a credit card where they get bonus money
um and they only spend what they have
month by month so essentially they're
never getting into debt
so i'm wondering should i consider
having a credit card or should i just
stick with having a credit a debit card
only
i'm so sorry for the silence i just find
it so funny when people call into
the ramsey show and ask us should we
have a credit card
you already know what i'm going to say
heather you know i mean
let me because he's taking his dave
ramsey course right now on high school
oh you are
high school you're taking it right now
yes sir how old are you heather
i'm 18. i just turned 18 about 20 days
ago 20 days with happy belated birthday
i'm gonna take it nice on you now cause
you a teenager i thought you was a grown
woman i was about to let you have it
right here on the ramsay show
but i'm gonna take it nice on you
because i love teenagers so listen
um i don't want to disrespect your
parents because you're still living in
their house and and i want to honor your
parents because
um you know they're your parents and
they've raised an amazing young lady
the fact that you're calling into the
show to ask me this question
let's your parents are doing something
absolutely amazing
um and so i want to respectfully say
this i disagree with your parents and i
disagree with your parents
uh from the standpoint of having a
credit
uh credit card just so i can get some
free miles
just so i can get some reward points
just so i can get some cash back
uh no and here's why heather
nearly 80 of people are living paycheck
to paycheck okay
uh about 90 of the people who have a
credit card carry a balance over
uh the credit card system works for them
it doesn't work for us
and so for me um i i've done it i
remember being your age at 18 years old
i remember having a credit card
and saying i'm gonna use it for
emergencies and never carry a balance
um and go from there and you know what i
carry the balance you know i carry the
balance because i had an emergency come
up because of a beautiful woman
and i want to take her to red lobster
okay
and so for me what i'm going to advise
you to do is don't worry about a credit
score
i want you to worry about cash i want
you to worry about building
wealth use your debit card the debit
card can do the exact same thing as
credit card
the only thing a debit card cannot do is
put you in debt
okay bottom line okay bottom line and so
i'm not telling you to go back and tell
your parents they're wrong
because i want you to respect your
parents yeah i really want you to
respect your parents
but when you as you're learning this
system as you are about to
graduate and go off into college i want
you to avoid
debt i want you to avoid credit cards i
want you to avoid student loans
i want you to avoid listening to your
peers and you know what as you get older
you may have to respectfully tell your
parents hey
i disagree mom and dad i'm a rock over
here i'm gonna do no debt i'm a
i'm a rock with no credit cards i don't
care about airline miles you know why
because i got money
and i could buy my own airplane ticket i
don't need no cash back
cuz i got cash